[Music]
okay so if you if you pay attention he
grabbed in a way where he set up that
right right cross because this is not
katata dodi right do you see how you
went that way okay so let's do let's do
katadori without the punch
right and you see where where he is so
now he's going to do
i'm sorry you're going to do what you
just did
but don't throw the punch and you're
going to see how different
that is you see that okay do you get
that so i'm not asking him
to uh grab here and then stick his hand
out there he's he's not going to hit me
from there
he has to come long oh he has to get
that thing going okay
so
um the energy that i have to use has to
be that energy
so i can't go
here and
this is no too late you see he already
touched you in fact he's already coming
in so if you pay attention he does that
same thing if i stay there there's no
way that's too much energy okay
so
he's already coming in this is where i'm
already out here
so things that mess you up
is
the same stop start kind of mentality is
like oh wait hold on wait okay no it
already started so i'm already moving
off the line
not here you're gonna get joked you're
going to get nailed
so you're already moving already moving
and then you follow the rules
center
just because you go you block here
you're not ignoring the arm
you you can still use this
but since he gave you the arm use the
arm so i use the arm
but i don't lose the grip that he's
given me
so i don't go here
i use it too
and then positioning
[Music]
okay let's try it again so the point i
offered was it it doesn't matter which
of the three basics he comes in whether
it's uh man
or yoga
man or ski
it doesn't matter okay
because i'm not going to be here
i'm going to do the art
again just like the network portion
tactically ezekiel right if he's going
to give you the other hand it's going to
be kokonage and to ikyo do you see
but strategically
the fight
is going to spiral
and i'm going to use the front inward
kazushi
okay
and then i'm not going to contest
and then technically i'm going to use
the ikea of the coq
to displace him into the front inward
kazushi pattern i'm just going to do
that every single time
will i do it the same way every single
time
no i won't okay do you get it
um so when i say
it doesn't matter if he skis or showman
or whatever
um
it does not matter
doesn't mean i can do them from the same
place
at the same time it does not mean that
okay
so
he
you can do whatever one you want to do
you see and so this he's more straight
now do you think
uh and then
you show the cross one again that you
like oh he's more this way
[Music]
he's more on this side do you think
um and then of course he's like the cro
it's like the cross doesn't that part
doesn't matter okay
so um
he goes and i'm relating to him
do you see
how in that spiraling
footwork okay
now i'm not waiting here
and i go to 12 and he goes to six this
fight has to start rotating immediately
okay
with how i move i start flanking him
immediately okay so that his next step
is on the curve and then i project him
across the curve with the coke here okay
uh and then the other thing the eye key
that i do is if he's gonna stick his
other hand up i'll use the other hand
you see
so we're here and i use the other hand
[Music]
so just like you're you're touching us
on your sword work i'll reach for the
sword you think
but i'm not
knocking his sword down that's what you
guys try to do so
uh
you go to yoko man you're like oh you
feel his power now here
okay
um so again
i'm moving moving
it doesn't matter which one it doesn't
matter which one
so
[Music]
they all feel exactly the same
but if you look
they're not done the same way